well there is an end of civilization
that isn't difficult to imagine because
civilization hasn't lasted that long in
the great scheme of this planet history
and it is a fragile thing which is
constantly pushing the earth's resources
to their limits as the population rises
towards the 9 billion mark as the
challenges of energy utilization become
ever more daunting as the risks of
climate change grow and more importantly
as the risks of of war grow larger
larger in the sense that weaponry has
never been more destructive than it is
today
then we certainly now have the
capability to destroy human civilization
and if we destroy human civilization we
certainly destroy history so the end of
history is conceivable but it didn't
happen in 1989 as Francis Fukuyama
famously suggested because what he meant
by the end of history was the triumph of
one model of social organization name of
Western liberal capitalist democracy
well I think even then it was a pretty
heroic assumption that that model was
going to prevail and become the only
model in town it's become an even less
credible hypothesis since 1989 clashing
civilizations have come along and spot
the story but it seems to me that this
is a misuse of of language though it
made for a great article title the end
of history can only really happen when
civilization ends and men and women
cease to be able to record their deeds
because that really is the cynic were
known for history